stories of real life and real lives
aware all documentary start when these
true stories are turned into great films
they can engage audiences with a special
intensity this year's documentary
masterpieces include two biographies of
brilliant but troubled artists and three
films about people fighting back against
oppression and injustice when politics
becomes deeply personal here are the
nominees for Best Documentary Feature
ami Asif Kapadia and James gay Ruth
cartel land
Matthew Hyneman and Tom Yellin the look
of silence Joshua Oppenheimer and Sima
Barroso Denton what happened miss Simone
and it's Garbus Amy Bobby and Justin
Wilkes winter on fire Ukraine's fight
for freedom evgeny fnaf ski and dental
mur
and the Oscar goes to
ami Asif Kapadia and James gay Rhys
the first Oscar and nomination for Asif
Kapadia and James Gary
oh well um thank you this is amazing
thank you to everyone in Academy and
wanted voted for us for the love you've
shown to the film to the contributors
everybody trusted us to actually make
this film really the songs all about Amy
this is all about showing the world who
she really was not a tabloid persona the
beautiful girl the amazing self funny
intelligent witty someone special
someone who needed looking after we just
wanted to make them to show what who she
really was
thank you to a24 the whole team in the
u.s. the gang on the corner our friends
the cinetic of really universal David
Joseph Adam Barker Chris King our editor
this is for you my friend and lastly
this is for the fans
Amy's fans who loved her through thick
and thin that was all she ever really
needed thank you very much and our
families and our wives and our children
thank you